foreign seeing the universe in a new way
distant galaxies and planets beyond
Earth that could potentially Harbor life
it used to be the stuff of futuristic
fantasy
the launch of the James Webb Space
Telescope on Christmas Day 2021
means this is no longer science fiction
what we're seeing when we look at these
images is the raw material for life
Webb is able to look back in time as far
as 13.5 billion years
and reveal galaxies as they looked
around the time when the Earth and Sun
were formed in never before seen
sharpness and Clarity but here's the
catch unlike its predecessor of the
Hubble telescope the snapshot's web is
sending are invisible to humans
our eyes can only see a small portion of
the total range of light
web is designed to see near and
mid-infrared wavelengths to show the
hidden regions of space
science visual developers Joe de
Pasquale and Elisa pagon work out of the
Space Telescope Science Institute in
Baltimore they have been tasked with
taking the data from Webb
and creating something the human eye can
see
we can't see in the infrared so there
has to be some level of translation here
but we use physical meaning like true
physical science in order to represent
sort of the color and it's the job of
Lisa and I to take that data to stretch
it so that we can see what's in the data
and then we apply Color according to
those wavelengths and so the the
shortest wavelength filters that we have
we used blue for those and as we move
into longer and longer wavelengths we go
to Greens and then Reds
Joe and Elisa have worked on other
images from telescopes like Spitzer and
Hubble but what they are seeing from web
is unlike anything else
the detail the clarity the color it all
just hit me all at once that yeah web is
a Next Generation Observatory it's gonna
you know change astronomy forever
to give you perspective on how powerful
web is here is a previous image that
Hubble captured in 1995 of The Pillars
of Creation
now here is what web is showing us web
is able to peer into the clouds in a way
that Hubble can't and to see stars in
the process of forming things that we've
never seen before are now showing up
[Music]
these glimpses into the beginning of
time have caught the attention of so
many including Canadian scientist Matt
Russo it's something completely foreign
to our everyday experience and so
there's always this sense of of intrigue
and wonder about what could be
discovered next what does it all mean
how did we get here
University of Toronto and a sonification
specialist
he has the unique ability to understand
the science data from the images and
translate it into sound
so he amped these up
[Music]
you could call them scientifically based
galactical musicals
[Music]
phonic interpretations with the help of
musician Andrew Santa Guida
the Trappist solar system was first
captured by NASA's Spitzer Space
Telescope in 2017. it was their first
effort at adding sound to the universe
which is an amazing solar system with
seven earth-sized planets but they also
happen to be locked in a musical pattern
called an orbital resonance that made it
really natural to convert their emotions
into musical rhythms and pitches
so it starts slow with one planer at a
time
[Music]
so that's all seven planets these are
the rhythms and pitches of these planets
it's one for Pure enjoyment then
took notice
how did you connect with NASA we kind of
just on our own we're just sonifying
different things they had released and
we would send it to them and they would
just start posting it on their own
and then eventually that led to us
working for them professionally
oh Matt and Andrew are working on the
latest in
and Elisa have created and putting it
through a software system matte designed
this is a small section of the Karina
nebula so it's a vast cloud of dust and
gas where our stars are forming so the
first step is to to break it up into
different components so in this case you
can see there's the bottom half which is
a red nebula and that's very distinct
from the top half which is a more
diffuse blue nebula so we can literally
just slice the image into those two
parts and treat them a little
differently and then there's of course
the thousands and thousands of stars
this is what stars sound like
[Music]
so in some cases we don't have much
control over the way the data sounds
sometimes it's a more direct translation
and we kind of just we're surprised as
anyone when the sound comes out in other
cases where we have a little more
musical input we have to decide for
instance which musical instrument is
going to be triggered by stars people
seem to have an intuition that stars
would make kind of like a bell or a
chime sound
[Music]
image brings new challenges and they try
to be as signed typically accurate as
possible
he did the sound for this black hole
[Music]
this is a real sound wave detected in
space in a galaxy cluster and we were
able to see the waves in the image which
means we can extract them and
re-synthesize a sound there were a lot
of people who were excited to see this
but what kind of feedback did you get
because there was a mix
some Outlets would say it's an actual
recorded sound of a black hole as if you
had a microphone in space which we know
would not work for several reasons so
it's important when we do sonification
to present it for exactly what it is
that it's it's data converged into sound
[Music]
there's a whole Community Christine
Malik is one of the people benefiting
from the sonification of the universe
blind since birth Matt's work allows her
to feel something she's never felt
before
what was your first impression when you
first heard what Matt created I was
blown away I had goosebumps on my
Goosebumps I had never imagined
experiencing astronomy in that way
moved by the music she reached out to
Matt
he wanted the perspective of a blind or
low vision person who hadn't seen the
images and whose only access was the
sonification so he asked if I would give
feedback on how much they did or did not
make sense to me so those little click
noises now she regularly helps both Matt
and the team at Nasa interpret images
for the visually impaired
they want this content to be available
simultaneously so that I have access to
this material at the same time as
sighted friends who are getting access
as well
foreign
telescope travels through outer space it
will continue to reveal secrets and
allow everyone a chance to experience a
world we could only once imagine when
you look at an image like this you're
looking at that raw material that is you
you are the universe trying to
understand itself in that moment and
that's something that is it's a very
unifying thing for anyone from any Walk
of Life to look at these images and
ponder that
thank you